ma che partiva ciao ragazzi non vogliono
notato scusate sto accarezzando la mia
pianta in questo momento la mia piccola
kendall seconda alla quale batte amo
sussurrare frasi dolci come sei
bellissima come il tuo padrone
oggi faremo una ricetta in particolare
una scelta che è stata richiesta spesso
in realtà tra le prime persone
la richiesta cioè il sottoscritto perché
perché stiamo parlando di uno dei miei
piatti preferiti ed è vero quest'anno il
suo sfavore
comunque sto parlando di uno dei miei
piatti preferiti in assoluto però allo
stesso tempo uno dei piatti che per
quanto semplicissimo io trovo
impossibile da fare e cioccolato un poi
rivolti mi sono sempre trovato ad avere
diciamo vari problemi ecco perché
all'interno di cucina buttata ho deciso
di invitare la persona che a detta sua è
il maestro di questo piatto stiamo
parlando della cacio e pepe e di mio
fratello gian luigi che però non è il
mio fratello preferito andiamo avanti da
mesi un paio di domande di nemi tutto da
me li ma ogni volta che però farà caso
il pepe diviene colla una falla caselle
o una un certo certo perché io il trucco
il segreto che svelerò in questo video
qualora lo vogliate e che tiene una
crema la crema perché il difficile farla
po annacquata o solidi in a col
formaggio un po le crociere cioè una
crema vai voglio far avvolge
secondo competente ogni tanto in questa
allora come fanno sempre passare come lo
chef di casa in realtà sono l'unico che
cucina mette in chiaro le cose
mettiamo in chiaro le cose io e per
questo format che a volte per ridere
sbaglia apposta punto ebbene sì certo
preferiamo sì sì certo
allora di cosa però ho paura ho visto
che è portato così di cosa avremmo
bisogno una padella e no grossa perché
c'è un trucco che andremo a fare
all'interno di una pentola per far
bollire la pasta questa basta e basta
ingrediente mix di pepi è chiuso non
diciamo la marca un tailleur e non
diceva mai amato e odiato che non ci
servirà perché non si usa nei aglio e
cipolla ragazzi assolutamente pecorino e
parmigiano cubi tu sei molto a me la
faccio parte certo ma sono i mezzi i
difficili non quei noiosi ok allora si
macchino ci vuoi dare una mano pur iter
e vieni con la forza mi trovo abbastanza
disorientati ragazzi e ragazze bebè no
io non ho mai fatta c'è il trucco
veramente che ci faremo alla fine
se sì sì sì ho sentito della pro capite
bene non ho mai affacciata è infatti
capace anche leggere
facciamo un figura tanto è tratto perché
in cucina buttata si sa è tutto nella
questo format di trascina nel baratro ma
pensa che figura di merda che non avete
chiamato mignone fratello sicuramente
seconda dai sti cavoli ricordiamoci il
salto di giallo aspetta magari ciardo il
saldo
la tua è una ricerca tra regionale la
mia è una ricetta tra dimensione sai
come youtube pronto a crocifiggere
infatti io ho preso perfettamente questa
ricetta da un sito romano top cioè
youtube vengono tenute al sapone qua
dentro la serata sei sicuro la lingua
come gandhi anche il bidet si fa così è
nel suo sito gli dice è un fazzoletto
più di passare lingua sotto le narici e
allora mi ha già salato l'acqua non sa
chi questa roba sarà il sali del nostro
piatto potere andare e quindi non ci
sarà l'acqua pochissimo guarda quanta ne
pensa
quanta acqua lascia così la nota
riguarda come state vandalizzate
verranno di stato
no davvero troppo se no secondo me era
da vera un possa far parte cinema levate
aspetta la marcia 5 minuti e mangiamo 65
media nostra famiglia ragazzi misure
[Risate]
allora ragazzi visto che mangiamo fra
cinque minuti la mia proposta è che ci
prendiamo per pranzo vizza questo
ovviamente una pizza che va mangiata
mammamia guarda quando fate il caffè
comunque vorrei dirvi una cosa o tutto
il caffè per terra quindi non sapete
versare i valori medi me mi dispiace ma
un po più noto questo campo
questa volta non me li faccio sempre
tutto il vostro caffè anche qui dai
com'è possibile click
e voi direste ma toglilo no
il tempo non me lo ricordavo la cosa che
faccio in più nella mia vita e prendere
il caffè da qui e di metterla in frigo
smacchiare i fornelli che vengono
lasciati federica futuro
questa è la mia vita ho bisogno di un
ufficio parola gusto è pronto sono nato
per forza territorio parmigiano
famiglietti e buti e separati io ti
senti più appoggio
mi piace la casa e pepe maestrale strano
che si trovano in bell'attore di casa
veramente pensa colpe golino che riesce
a creare o pazzo da in parmigiano
variazione all'autore del pecorino
eccezionale un altro punto poco
già ma che c'entra con la cucina questo
[Risate]
pecorino tirata più morbido per lui col
parmigiano un cerchio di polvere e
facendoti una chips di parmigiano che
poi andremo a modellare dentro a quel
coppino tondo che ci farà da piatto di
portata per lo slam ma eccezionale il
piatto è solo parmigiano parmigiano il
primo video aziende per me un po come
leve fatto quando ho guardato questa
mattina un video sempre su quel sito che
dicevo prima
vai di ronde 180 c'era il papà vaia vaia
che ne sai mai cosa che bello è farlo
sciogliere un altro koch i cestini
quando ti vedi sono un pochino più
ambrati siamo troppo valida ovvero poco
me lo sento è perfetto ti dirò anche i
più non
non va bene lascia lascia grazie a stare
c'è lewis non soffi aspettiamo su un
coso più stretto c'hai ancora più
stretto ferma questa già si sta
attaccando vedi che negare scelta molto
bello allora mettiamo la pasta prodotta
collage all uscio estesa così bella con
dita la palla adesso fai toscani giusto
estraiamo dal baby tutte le sue i suoi
aromi tutti poi profumi e sapori come si
sente ragazzi altri dato viene adesso
ma che cosa hai fatto che questo
attrezzo credo che sia un errore di
luigi roba della friggitrice quale lo
rinfacciata all'infinito no non è luigi
per veramente tanto rinfacciato io sono
così e tirò fuori il peggio di nemo
meyer è solamente per lasciare andare
vai sfuma con l'acqua di cottura il per
l'innovazione innovazioni culinarie
ragazza viene adesso ragazzi abbiano del
momento ci accingiamo a effettuerà re
ricordo che si possono effettuare e che
tu era l'effetto è a effettuare il passo
della casa e pepe ti chiedo a te ma
metti un po di parmigiano all'interno
del pecorino la metà la metà pry la metà
bello abbondante ci piace bello
formaggio zoe pastello signori qui
pochissima emessa e stai castellan
domandiamo a sfibrare tutti i grumi
altrimenti vi ritroverete tutti dentro
al piatto o crei una crema già il
pastello
guardate guardate che crema di formaggio
guardate adesso il piatto è pronto ma
proprio il gatto è pronto dobbiamo
solamente aspettare la pasta veramente
una ricetta semplicissima da ragazzi la
cacio e pepe
nasce da una cucina povera perdente è
raccomando come salata ma chi è che
apparecchia ruxelles incredibile come
questo lo fuoco abbia due mani destre
saporito da colpe per 3 minuti e ci
siamo noi la volgare l'altro giorno vi
dice no è no allora ragazzi andiamo a
impiattare mike fratello non c'era
funzionano funzionato wow ragazzo bravo
bravo d'abbraccio l'agone far sciogliere
tutto in una padella abbastanza mi sento
una clerici lei molto inumidite umida
questo perché l'amico della vostra è
uscito prendiamo la fiamma
symantec ha buoni dal fuoco questi
pastello e cominciamo sa il fatto suo
questo set ragazzi davide meraviglie
esauriti la pasta per ragazzi io è
l'unica volta che sono fatta allora già
così va bene secondo me è troppo
formaggio andrebbe a prender troppo
folla sentiamo un goccino di ago sì ma
proprio non nulla si 1 annullati dire
che ipad
ovviamente tre grandi maestri della
pittura è assurda e bella bella prima
vorrei mangiare in piatta sì ma anche
nuovi ti perché si senta tutti c'è stata
una magia da questo vado con i ragazzi
che bravo guglielmo bravo pepe fermi
perché questa qui è la doppia rosa c'è
santo questa parte larga sul fondo è il
pulmino perfetto chiude molto bene molto
bene mamma mia guglielmo e alla porzione
voldemort e rapina ta ta ta ta esatto
bellissimo questo piatto la gara
impianto la prima di fare l'assaggio vi
invito a iscrivervi a questo cane se ti
è piaciuto questo video mettere un
pollice in su per il di ognuno di noi
quindi almeno 4 pollici in su e lasciare
un po meno costoso fatemi sapere per
esempio qual è la vostra versione dei
dragoes e pepe avete quando qualcosa
sarà fatto in maniera diversa sapete i
consigli se avete delle varianti
interessanti
fatemelo sapere perché sono curioso e
anche perché il mio piatto preferito
detto ciò proviamo la allora ti togliamo
la giammarco non ha voluto aspettare
niente si sia della persona
io lo trovo molto buona ragazzi merita
una crea malti ora cerco così nel
ristorante ha fatto una buonissima e
tutto sembra però mi avete crepato
entrate vi avessi lasciato
come dice che dice ma non è masticato
lingue gita certo se mi sarà il piatto
con la grossa per 88 ad una sola volta a
me da me stacul st ciotola del cane che
altro dire ragazzi ci vediamo a questo
punto con un blog con un blog con un
blog disputato scusare un blog
altrimenti se avete sempre seguire
solamente con una buttata domenica
prossima sempre al 12 ciao aspettano
volevi fare un'analisi dettagliata del
piatto buona cremosa t7 ragione ti
sembra ottimo bravo giallo